[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett it's time once again for another
candid conversation with someone
interesting from the internet this time
we are conversing with the creator of
the amazingly successful YouTube channel
Epic Meal Time the sauce boss himself
Harley Morenstein we talked to him about
his very hyperactive childhood and also
just how many things he tried before he
became a success on YouTube with Epic
Meal Time and also what kind of mindset
results in a successful YouTube series
and the relational casualties that are a
byproduct of that mm-hmm but you know
okay so I you know I'm excited about you
guys here in this conversation we had
with Harley but I will say that we have
a chip on our shoulder we have a pilot I
said we have a beef with Epic Meal Time
Oh pawn because I'm very into puns yes
you are and well okay it is a little bit
more of a chip maybe it's like a potato
chip on our shoulder to use it's not
really an epic Meal Time spawn well no
but it's just food okay meaning that I'm
glad you know I hardly is a friend and
I'm glad they're successful and we went
red is trying to say that he stole our
idea no I am saying that first of all I
feel like it's in one sense our past the
there's a lot of ideas in our past that
we do something and it kind of doesn't
work and then a couple years later we
see somebody else do it and they're like
oh and we're that's how it's supposed to
be done that's how it's supposed to be
done and be done successfully okay so
you're talking about we made an epic rap
battle and then it turns out you add of
history to it and it just turns out to
be one of the most amazing musical
series in the history of the internet
and in not V in and if and when we have
the opportunity to talk to nice Peter
about that we'll tell him we'll talk
about that but in the case of Epic Meal
Time our story is that you go all the
way back to 2000 it was probably 2004
2005 when we made a video
called the burger Zeebo we invented a
fake fast-food restaurant called Burgas
B you are Gaz right and the only item
sold at burgers was well two items it
was the bur gazebo which was a burger
that looked like a gazebo it was like
held up by like edible sticks of some
kind well they weren't edible and that
was supposed to be edible in the in the
you know in the fake world of the burger
Z we made a fake commercial we showed
the gazebo shaped burger and then we
made some videos where we went and I had
a mega tater I wanna oh yeah it was the
mega tater commercial which was a really
large french fried it was just one
french fry that you would put in a
french fried box it was just a huge big
ol basically a baked potato well a raw
potato was shaved into the shape of a
you know a square or whatever so we may
I mean not really epic meals but just
kind of ridiculous that was the that was
the seed to an idea that later happened
in 2008 was that summer 2008 that we did
the alka-seltzer good American road trip
yeah so part of one of the videos as
part of that great American road trip
was in Chicago in doing this idea where
we were like what is the best food what
is the best food in Chicago is it the
Italian beef is it deep-dish pizza or is
it the hotdog because those are like the
three main food offerings from Chicago
and we had this idea hey what if we put
all these together and we created what
we call an epic meal the Chicago ziba we
did not use the terms epic or meal no he
didn't we could time the Chicago Zebo
which wasn't a huge double-decker
Italian beef pizza that was held
together by basically like a gazebo but
the pillars of the gazebo were large
hotdogs I think our problem is we
thought the key to this thing was it
needed to be shaped like a gazebo and
that doesn't matter at all it just needs
to be epic and melee in these videos I
don't know if the the burger Zeebo
videos are still on the internet but I
know the Chicago Zeebo is still on our
Channel and you can see that we went on
WGN we went on that the WGN motion show
Chicago and we sang a jingle we
introduced the Chicago z-bo on the air
anyway no one cares about the video it
hardly has any
use but you know it just it hits me when
I when I when I think about epicMealTime
I was like you know what were we doing
wrong I mean we had this crazy creation
that was a pizza and hot dogs and
Italian beef all together in the shape
of gazebo we even wrote a song about it
but it just didn't work for us yeah all
the elements didn't come together I mean
if you want to know how to do it look at
their first video and everyone afterward
right you know and the thing that I love
about our conversation with Harley is
that you see everything that led up to
him coming up with that idea and then
how he was so ready to execute it and
pull the trigger once he saw a little
bit of success or maybe what at the time
was a lot of success so let's get into
this conversation with Harley amazingly
successful almost 6 million subscribers
on youtube.com slash Epic Meal Time and
over 600 million views here it is our
ear biscuit is it an epic biscuit I
think it's just a regular ear biscuit
but I mean this is epic this is about as
epic as an air biscuit as you can have
in terms of the meal analogy here's our
conversation with Harley why don't you
take us back we like to go back to the
the not the conception but you know our
the inception but the the beginnings of
Harley uh all right I got some good
stuff what are you from I'm from
Montreal Canada so it's like six hours
north of New York it's very French
I'm fully English uh you speak French
yeah they force you you have to learn
French if you were I'm some French
honest hot to mention no I hate the way
I sound I speak French very ugly to Mars
led back on Baku just we Renee just we
Aloha
those are good those are good accent
listen my French you know Bonjour Mon Oh
a Harley has a memoir the lair diet coke
avec mares at me read a link so in other
words you don't try to to cop the French
accent at all no oh no I can't like cuz
then it's just it's it's almost this
fake attempt at trying to like I would
be acting in my speaking you know right
listen if it's like a roll and I gotta
embrace it then maybe I would approach
it as such but to just talk to you guys
like I don't really speak French like
that so why would I you know like even
you guys did voices when you spoke
French you know no no no no that was
that's my voice that's not your friend
speak French in a French accent I think
I actually kind of had of like an
Italian thing going honestly but yeah we
both had a horrible thing going it's a
beautiful language very musical I'm just
not a musical or beautiful person so I
don't really carry the language that
well but people in Montreal going around
speaking French this is what they say so
when you're when you're 16 years old
like I live in the West Island at 75
percent English that place but it's in a
city that's you know 75 percent French
but when you go for a job you sit down
for your interview and he'll start
asking you questions and then halfway
through he'll just turn to French and
you have to turn to French and keep
going and then he'll have a conversation
with you and French and English as he's
interviewing you and it's not like yeah
if you don't do the French party you're
like sorry can you say that in English
you're sorry I didn't get the job son
Kylie yeah you blew it didn't speak
French properly so in grade school I
rearrange that or in your house so if
you're I mean you guys can research
further but this is from what I believe
and it's pretty close to this or it was
like this at one point I'm not exactly
sure if this is how it is now but if
your parents one of your parents are
both your parents are immigrants
you must learn French you must be in a
French school so all French so that
means like everything is French except
for English class and this is this is
what's messed up is because you learn
you know math a certain way and then you
get to fourth grade now your
is in French and if you're not grasping
math the last thing you want to do is
learn it in two languages
yeah that's French numbers are the same
though right yeah numbers are the same
numbers are the same but saying them out
loud is you know it's that's where it
like it's for example what is it you
know uh you know bummed ass yeah been
bass brackets exponents multiplication
division yes the order of which you
approach something orders operation so
this is the time that I'm getting to
that in the fourth grade them -
associative and then you get then you
get to French and now bem - is something
different because all those letters are
different words so like it's that's just
an example fractions you want to talk
fractions it's like you know two thirds
in in French
duty are it's like something completely
different right that's where it gets
confusing so in fourth grade your life
got turned upside down when it comes to
math and language I brag I'm good I was
good okay I was good at French not
speaking it but I can read it I can
understand it but I was just kind of
speaking just I became a teacher later
on in life and I just loved it stuff
like that differently I like just when I
started to see how people teach you
stuff like that like that was in those
weird to me because it's like what's the
point of teaching math and French and
you know it's the whole French thing
it's it's cool but I just remember it
being a headache at the time I don't if
you guys ever read Malcolm Gladwell
books I have actually haven't actually
read one but I do know point all this
stuff yeah this whole thing of like why
you know his theory of white Chinese
people are better at math and it comes
down to at the basic form just numbers
themselves are shorter and easier to
remember and instead like you know stay
it's not set up so sinks I'm like 11 12
13 you say 10 1 10 to 10 3 so when you
speak it it scent makes better sense
than when you're like 6 and you're like
what the [ __ ] is at 12 1 2 3 4 10 and
then what's at 12 and then it's 22 mmm
it's now 12 is abandoned 12 is its own
word for you know rent - but in China
it's like you know - 10 2 3 10 - 10 100
a word is 10 10
in Chinese Samara multiplication yeah
exactly so so he was saying that you
know because it's easy to grasp just in
a language base they're more and when
you're good at something you'll do more
of it so the kids are better at math
because they grasp it easier just from
the way that they speak and you know
then it just they try harder at it and
just trying harder at it makes you
better at it later in life because you
you know follow a certain path whereas
when you're huh graduate or you drop out
of school because you're like math you
know I'm super good at it and sports
great cool but what but then there's
kids you know it's like they're learning
French for you know geography like now
right no United States you're trying to
find where it is on the map but here's
the catch it is a different name now now
it's called a tazuna and so it's like
that messes you up so you're trying to
grasp these two languages and life at
the same time but it makes you smarter
well it makes a smart visual brain but
now I'm happy because now I come to LA
you know and French is cool to know you
speak French and it's like yeah and then
I say things you know say something and
shins burger like bacon extra meal what
does that mean just means me beautiful
but really I'm just I just said
cheeseburger with bacon extra mayonnaise
and a French accent but it doesn't
matter just knowing French is a cool
thing now and now it's like I download
like duolingo on my iPhone I can I'm
gonna learn Spanish to I do it a little
bit I don't really learn anything but
yeah it's cool I wish I learned I wish I
learned six languages growing up you
know my brother talks to his kid in like
Spanish they don't even know Spanish but
they throw all these Spanish words at
the kid and learn sentences and throw it
at the kid maybe they pick up some
Spanish too you know
so okay so you were you were good at
that you were good in school even over
that obstacle well let's bring it back
after second French I actually in first
grade okay mm-hmm and the first grade we
had our teacher and and this other
teacher would come Miss Monroe and when
everyone was doing like the alphabet and
math like she would come and get Harley
Douglas and Newton and we would go to
roll clay ball
so like when I was like five or six and
Miss Monroe would come yeah yeah like
we'd like play with clay or they'd show
us how to hold a pencil and like trace
okay
so everyone's like doing like writing
and I would stand up like suckers I'm
willing miss Monroe she's so nice and so
encouraging yeah and at the end of grade
one I'll never forget this the teacher
did this she goes everyone passed except
for Douglas and Newton and I remember my
heart stopped
gin-san Harley I don't never forget that
she said it in front of the class the
whole teacher and it's like 91 but still
he's a 91 that's like what 20 30 years
20 years ago right yeah so like it's
just different time announce it in front
of the kids - kids failed and it wasn't
me and I was happy cuz redoing all that
would have destroyed me if I had to do
that sooner I went into grade - and
that's when I was good at school now
what was this some demented art teacher
was I was [ __ ] in grade one right
and like yeah Harley is [ __ ] like
Douglas Newton or mentally slow I don't
know the exact word of what I was okay
and I don't want to hurt anyone's
feelings out there if we if we keep
going with my life we'll get to the part
where I work with mentally challenged
people so I want to go around the r-word
right listen listen you know I don't
know how to describe myself as anything
else than [ __ ] so they I went with
Douglas Newton who when I was in grade
one I was like these guys can weird you
know like Douglas didn't speak Douglas
couldn't speak and Newton fought
everyone and I swear to god he was four
years older than everyone what do you
get group with them two reasons or or
curious one I was [ __ ]
maybe that's worked in you my my mom
like a neurotic Jewish mom was like I
want to make sure my boy really gets
help and and he's gonna get this extra
care or you know I'm gonna make sure my
son is or maybe she was like my son's a
little [ __ ] but um you know who
knows or maybe I want my son to learn
how to roll balls out of cameras like
you knows I feels like I'll never forget
because was like Christmastime and we
were like taking Klan she was like
enrolled
balls like smooth out the line so it's
perfectly smooth out looks like Joe this
is awesome
and I got my buddy Matt Wilson in there
like writing the alphabet Thunder you
made it in under the wire into second
great you got it we got a second Greg
comes around okay
subtraction comes into the picture and
just like that
addition subtraction like I like I was
literally like math and I swear I was
the best at at math and grade two I'll
never forget that like I got like eight
pluses you guys do you guys ever have
mad minutes a mad minute mad minute was
the sickest thing I've ever get angry
with each other but no madman it is like
it's the teacher would give you a piece
of paper and it's flipped upside down
and you have one minute but K flip it
over now and your time and you'd flip
over the mad minute and it's just like
30 examples like you know 2 minus 1 3
plus 4 and you've got a you do the whole
thing 1 7 1 minute and if the teacher if
you make a mistake on the first one
that's where she stops correcting you
know oh and if you get 30 out of 33 I'm
not having a streak and you can't make a
mistakes where ever you make a mistake
that's where she stops and that's cool
cuz you would do it and like and then
you would flip it over when you're done
and you would go just but you would say
that loud enough so the other kids knew
that you were done so near like the
forty second 55 seconds all these kids
were like crazy and right at the end and
when I was I killed those nice garden I
didn't know understand how the alphabet
translated into looking up words in a
dictionary no this couldn't been
kindergarten when you started looking up
words in a dictionary and having to
write the definition I mean what was
this first second grade looking upward
yeah that's gotta be about maybe third
grade you were learning how to write
like I have kids who I should know this
right I remember not really knowing how
to look up words in the dictionary to
write the definition and I got little
camel to look him up for me really then
I would write down the definition I was
I could I did not know about that or
alphabetical order
yeah do you want us to explain it now or
do you know it now I figured it out
later thanks to the aw how long did it
take till you figured it out I don't
know maybe by the next year I think I
don't remember when I got it but I
do remember the instance when I didn't
have it and I was like oh I'm I'm losing
it here I need Lynwood you got to help
me buddy
okay so that's what things were like at
school what about home what kind of home
did you grow up in I have an older
brother and an older sister my sister
seven years older than me that my
brother's nine years older than me
I got a mom and dad my dad's really pink
so I really pink like addition got pink
skin he's just like a white ass mouth
like a like a baby pig like he has to
wear like a hat and the Sun okay he's
like just like a pink ass like he's hair
all my buddies call him Papa pink yeah
and they're still together your pink
yeah yeah yeah he's got my dad's got a
nickname doghouse money that's like his
Twitter don't go look at those really
geeky so you got this like Jewish family
they devout Jewish that work they're
like you know they're like oh go to
synagogue on Yom Kippur cuz you know
Zadie you'll be sad if you know so like
guilt-tripping me Jewish guilt tripping
me into Jewish holidays mmm it's a tea
with your grandfather grandfather
grandfather bubbies a tea our
grandmother grandfather and you know I
would go and do like I would go to some
holidays like I would join him at the
synagogue like you know go there for a
couple hours for that but like I mean
you know we didn't milk and meat bacon
and cheese there was no we weren't that
Jewish so the whole the the later in
life when bacon became a pretty big part
of your identity it wasn't like there
were Jewish relatives who were like the
only thing that happened is in one
episode I put a pig head on a plate and
give it to someone in an episode who's
wearing a Tallis and a kippah something
like no no looks at her like sad and
like and then yeah so he was an actor
and so that episode when my parents saw
you can't do that you can't sound like
we're talking about and they're like the
Jewish community will write you off for
some some [ __ ] or not you know as a
car bomb the Jewish community like it
didn't matter you know anyways I ended
up doing it like I ended up still being
written in like the combined Jewish
magazine like like the next two weeks
later but it's just funny cuz written up
meaning reprimand
I interviewed inter okay so you're you
were the youngest child yep does that
mean you were spoiled as a child yeah
it's definitely spoiled like my brother
you know my brother got made fun of like
when he went to school cuz you know the
my parents are driving like a poas
vehicle but by the time I come around
ten years later it's like they're more
human now my parents what did they do
both had jobs
my dad's a contractor windows and doors
my mom was a secretary at like an
accessories place like belts and stuff
like that she doesn't do that anymore
no shouldn't do that anymore now she
ships t-shirts for epicMealTime she is
an employee yeah up in Montreal
yeah and whenever this time I know my
mom causes problems I'm like y'all
what's up with the t-shirt orders and
she's like there's some where I'm like
mom there's a lot of other moms out
there that would love to work for Epic
Meal Time right now so you can shut up
and ship these t-shirts you know so
that's your mo hire moms you're like
it's working I'm gonna keep this going
it's actually it's funny we had a I
think like a relationship with a t-shirt
company before that and they were just
they just fell apart they didn't they
just didn't expected the man when we
first epicMealTime first rolled out of
church there was just bacon strips shirt
that sold like crazy and this company
they just instead of handling it or like
just like saying like we can't do it or
whatever they just kind of shut down and
it ended up being this ugly stink and
I'm almost like well I'm gonna clean up
this mess for my boys you know it just
came in as he's been an employee -
killed it she just did it yeah but have
you added belts because I mean she knows
about that kind of thing shed that's it
that's when it comes to buying and
purchasing she had already had the
experience we don't do the belts though
we did have belts - a hot topic for a
while oh you did yeah they said bacon
strips on it it was like a Cadillac
seatbelt and I said like bacon strips on
the belt very pretty neat yeah so tell
us more about growing up in that
household oil well you know like buy
spoiled I mean bike by comparison to how
my brother experienced it you know but
my brother like you know my brother and
sister like they still had a Nintendo
no entertainment system you guys will
you're reborn in so a time a seven so
you're my brother's age was having a
Nintendo Entertainment System like a big
deal
absolutely you guys have those yes
okay that's because you made it a point
right like you needed the Nintendo oh my
god like really wanted it but my brother
had a Nintendo like you know and when I
grew up like video games became like a
big deal to me because I just like grew
up watching my brother like beat Mike
Tyson's punch-out you know and then like
I'm playing it later and then you know
and then shortly after that like Mortal
Kombat rolls out so when when Hanukkah
was coming around like it was a big deal
that I got like a Sega Genesis or a
Super Nintendo mhm but I was spoiling
the sense of like in the third grade I
had a TV in my room with the Sega
Genesis and that was like a big deal
like I had like a little TV Sega Genesis
like that's how I was spoiled when I got
through high school I realized I'm not
so spoiled because I had a lot of rich
friends and I couldn't even like roll
with them on the weekend because
something would like you know I'd get
you know I'd have like twenty bucks for
the week basically and this is out like
14 years old and I'd go and go hang on
the buddy and be like yeah let's uh
let's get a lunch sure like let's get
some beers it's like yeah we're gonna
badasses and drink beers yeah it's like
let's go for dinner it's like no my
money's done it's like well we're going
to party after that and tomorrow we're
going to the water slides and but well I
already used my twenty bucks so I I
guess I'm gonna I guess I'm gonna roam
the streets lighting things on fire
right and what kind of game were you
were you were you a troublemaker I think
people would want to believe that you're
a Hellraiser as a kid I was very loud I
was like like my parents would go pick
me up at my friend's house and his
parents would be like if Harley's gonna
come over again in the future
he can't have soda pop and stuff like
that because he's very wild you know
like I would do things like like like
throw myself down the stairs friend
magnet for entertain yeah and like
scream and like you know like a run and
scream and you know like I was the kid
like as soon as I was done eating at
dinner I would like slide under the
table I'm like you know like crawl out
and like give me the keys to the car
are and you know I want to go on the
card one outside only another restaurant
anywhere last crazy kid I played
football at the time as well and
basketball
why were you like that you just didn't
get spanked enough no I got I got socked
a bunch times my dad he'd slap yeah that
was cool
actually I genuinely thought that was
great
my my buddies as well like they also
would get whacked by their parents if
they looked around are you thought you
said slap do you mean spank or no or
like a like like a slap like a on the
face yeah like shut the really yeah yeah
we've definitely liked the car like I'm
gonna pull this car right off over if
you guys don't shut up back there
it's typically when someone would say
that it would be like in a moment of
anguish confession of abuse but you seem
to be saying is like I have I have
because you know what I was a wild kid
like you have to imagine this I'm 10
years old like it's the 4th grade and
I'm five nine right and I'm I'm insane
I'm insane so I had an older brother so
my brothers like would beat me up all
the time like you know you get beat real
the brothers friends like that but like
I was always antagonizing I was like a
really big antagonize er like no one
ever hurt me you know like there was
never like a black eye or anything like
that but like no I've been like slapped
on the cheek numerous times and my
buddies their parents would slap them on
the cheeks as well when I grew up like
if you [ __ ] up like your parents gonna
slap you are you gonna get a slap yeah
that's how it worked and I was good cuz
I had like I had like a goofy bunch of
friends we were all crazy so it didn't
really help no but at the time like case
by case you know like I'm in the back
like yelling screaming pulling my
sister's hair my dad reaches back and
whack it's like you know now I'm like
seeing the corner man go y'all you know
just the way it was the amount of times
I thought is it worth a slap right now
my buddy he his dad was great his dad
would slap him and give him like an ese
lately yeah like his like my paper she
stole from his mom once like was
stealing like you know like five dollar
bills here and there then his dad like
marked one he took the five dollar bill
and like came home and his dad was like
let me see and he was like this is my
money I found it and there's a little
mark on it whack I was there for the
slap live when your body's getting slap
you're just like you get like a little
shiver you know right little shiver like
goose bumps like oh yeah I can't wait to
go home and not be getting slashed and
then and then like he's also slapped
with an essay hmm yeah like like it was
intense really yeah grace so good it was
just a great punishment I remember being
like young and being like I'm like ten
and I'm like that
I say that's crazy that's crazy like not
even for school or anything just for dad
cuz you stole from mom so that it ever
progressed the point where you know
you're having to get disciplined at
school or I mean go to jail no see the
thing is at school I was always I did
really well
but I my teachers were always calling my
parents like mm-hmm
you know harley's not getting enough
attention at home he keeps making jokes
like he's always making jokes that was
my thing like class clown to the maximum
and and like ridiculous
class clown antics as well like falling
onto the first desk like when I walk in
and like just being loud and and it's
funny because when I was a teacher later
on in life mm-hmm it was like I I
experienced the Karma of that I sat
there and watched some kids and I was
like so unfunny such like jokes there
and their buddies are laughing and I'm
there and I'm like I deserve this like
their buddies don't think it's funny but
they're laughing cuz it's how it works
in high school and I'm like and now I
get it
cuz now I'm the teacher and like I got
to sit there while like you know those
kids like throwing papers and his
buddies are laughing and it's just like
it's not funny and I'm like this is what
I get it all it all comes back right
like closed it off like I remember like
in high school I faked a seizure on a
teacher's desk
well my buddy filmed it like it was like
a whole thing I like I was like oh mr.
rose I have a like I fall on his desk
I'm rolling around this is like the time
that like Tom Green's really popular
yeah so I'm like just enjoying that type
of stuff and and we had this awesome
video file of me like shaking and like
like on the desk and the teacher knows
my antics is just sitting there not
moving does it move muscle and like just
lets me like roll off and walk away and
like I understand him now but I was like
you see that [ __ ] I'm all about his
desk and he's like he could just see
there can't do you know - bro that's bro
and then now as a teacher like I
understand you're just like this there
is nothing you could do to help this
child yeah so I I ended up getting it
back my first time teaching ever
I was substituting for my brother and
I'm I'm sitting at the desk and this
teacher this stood like these kids come
in and I'm kind of setting up and this
kid walks in like real slow like
cigarette on his ear and he looks over
me and goes as he goes who's this like
to everyone and that's like major
offense right so I'm I'm there I'm now
it's the first I'm having my first
confrontation live in high school me
first is unknown 14-year old former mean
yeah he's got a cigarette on his ear and
I'm like got like a pink polo shirt
tucked in I feel like dress pants and
I'm like I'm just doing it like I just
needed something fancy was one of the
only things I had that a collar on it
that'll do it and I'm just there and I'm
like okay
I'm going to pretend like I didn't hear
it and I'm just kind of like humming let
that slide right yeah I like yeah and
then select they're just loud kids and
stuff like that and I got Mike you know
trying to get control no one's
controlling so I was taught in
elementary education not high school so
I I go over and I shut the lights off
and cross my arms because that's what
you do in elementary school and then
high school there's no windows in the
room the lights are off for like a split
second when I'm like oh pitch black back
on desks like four desks got flipped
over and like everyone's standing like
just instantly and I'm like oh man I'm
blowing it
anyway that's just my first encounter at
at school and that's when I was like
this is gonna be like a slow like
balancing of my Karma for how I was in
high school and it was I had like I had
bat like some bad classes I love all the
kids they're great but like there's just
like disturbers Amega who they were and
I knew I was disturbed when you learn
later on like you know you probably
could have done so much better with the
girls in high school if you weren't
being a disturber I watch that every
time and it like the girls when I watch
like the female students never are
impressed by jackassery of male students
and it's like this weird parading and
beating of the chest that I definitely
took part in they're kind of embarrassed
and yeah it's just they get it like
that's how you know like they're more
mature like to just know it's just like
you know obnoxious and stuff then what's
your journey with the ladies like see
here's the thing I used to go to Juke
camp in the summers Jewish camp is
basically so throwback you know to the
hitler times camps were made to erase
Jewish people basically right Jewish
people made camps to introduce Jews to
Jews so Jews will make more Jews you've
got it so like a Jewish camp you go
there for you know 60 days it's
sleepaway and you know here's your your
are you supposed to mate they're your
tensile here I'll tell you your tensor
here the girl tents are like you know 30
feet away and you have counselors that
sleep in there but the counselors go out
at night and they like go in and be like
hey guys turn out the lights don't go
sneaking into the girls tents I don't
like they don't make more Jewish people
yeah base wink don't go doing something
we wouldn't do and then you know they
leave you and then you go and you know
obviously like run across and finger
some girls cuz that's to camp and you
know maybe a little hand job in the
woods or something like that you know do
camp yeah you suck on boobies and stuff
like that and you just maybe just suck
on a pair of boobies at 16 and you know
fast forward eight years you're still
together and you guys are making Jewish
babies now so it's like a breeding
ground so the way it works is when I was
younger and I would do all that ah sure
but when I would get to Jewish camp and
I would like a girl
she's trapped you can't go anywhere it's
camp like if you don't like me today or
tomorrow or the next day or a week from
now like I'm still here mm-hmm
and I'm still gonna like you how long is
the camp it's 60 days that's a lot of
time where a girl down exactly so you
know by the time the 60 days are up I
you know if I put a finger a girl for
each finger basically at the end of it
mm-hmm
but then you know you go to school it's
more than one week school is a different
ball game
school like you know there was a I don't
know I didn't really like have have the
money to kind of play or the freedom
with my parents to kind of just you know
go out and like just hook up with girls
or go on dates really plus I never took
things seriously I was never good at
like asking a girl out on a date not
being a goof but I can only see things
in like a goofy way I was very childish
yeah it only took until probably my last
years of high school that I start
realizing you know there's an art to
this right then what happened towards
the end of high school
towards the end of high school I mean I
graduated like it like a jackass while
walking to get my diploma every every
year I would get principals on a roll
and I would go get my diploma and I
would fall on purpose unlike the
principal there was almost a different
ability okay oh my god like help me up
you know they grab my diploma and limp
off it was like a thing it's like when I
graduated I actually I took a big spill
like a huge one and the principal again
came but like everyone knew I was gonna
fall and they all stood up like you know
I start applausing clapping and I have
this like awesome you know standing
ovation this awesome video like really
bad quality unlike my dad's old cell
phone of me falling and and everyone
like just standing up and you know did
your parents know you're gonna do this
they they knew my dad knew I told him
and then what does he say he's like
shake his head or he's like that was
like that culminated yeah my dad thought
is all right but that culminated and
summed up my high school experience like
here's this big dummy like just falling
on his face and like you know just being
an idiot and just doing it for like
claps really like what are the clap
you know at this time when you kind of
developing an idea of what you wanted to
do I was working at summer camp I went
to summer camp every year cuz you know I
was always trying to get it up so I just
pounding lots of summer camp bringing
back year after year I went back to
staff because on your staff you just get
that much more Jewish I would go back to
camp all these years I'm working with
children I liked it it was fun and then
so I decided to go into education
because it'll actually make my mom happy
my dad will be happy and I am also
worried that if I go into filming I'll
waste my time and it'll just be like
that was stupid so and then I went into
university and I ended up being in
education there as well and I go to
school McGill University in Montreal
yeah it's in Montreal it's it's a good
school it's good school and so I went
there and I started doing education and
that was great because there's actually
there were some classes where I'm an
elementary education there might be 350
people and there's me and a gay black
dude and everyone else's girls really
yeah like the program like I would do
group work and it would be me and like
six girls and yeah I don't know my
advice if anyone out there is the type
of person like this were some national
lampoon's script go into education yeah
was anything did anything formative come
from that the school and before you
became a teacher I hated school I hated
it I hated it like cuz University was
modeled to be like kind of like a
elementary or high school atmosphere so
we would go into classes and we would
like do counting with like M&Ms and
stuff like that and you know everything
that like we would we would experience
lesson plans meant for kids to like we
would teach one another elementary basic
stuff like that's how we learned like to
learn how to think like a child
almost in a weird like it was like to
get you back like you would do all this
learning them it was like a night let's
bring it back to grade one what's an
interesting thing to teach kids how to
do the alphabet and trick them into
learning the alphabet without them
knowing that they're doing the Alpha
you know what's something fun oh we can
show them how to draw a picture where
there's letters as the picture there's a
million things just but we would welcome
any lesson plans and do it to each other
and yeah I didn't I wasn't a fan of it
because teaching wasn't my passion
that's doing it as a plan-b and right
you know I go into the first class and
it's like you know I'm uh people would
be like yeah like I'm here because my
mom was a teacher and my mom's mom was a
teacher and now I get the children yeah
and they're crying and then it gets to
me and it's like I work with kids and
I'm pretty good at it so I don't give so
already it's like I'm working with these
people and if you ever been around
something like where everyone's so
passionate about and you're just like
whatever it makes you more whatever yeah
yeah it makes like just Black's about
the kids that you're not teaching yet
right relax bring it back and I was
always late but my antics carried over
into university to an extent
I was always late as you guys know I
something I never figured out and as a
teacher I showed up thirty minutes late
to this podcast everyone by the way as a
teacher like you can't be late you can't
show up to class late they don't teach
there so they're 14 and there's 30 of
them you know leave them for 10 minutes
alone because you're late they're not
gonna sit for the teacher to come so in
a elementary education like it's like
you I show up late to class all the
teachers give you it's like you can't do
this you can't be late and it's not like
a big university class for the most part
there were some where you could just
show up really late and or not show up
like they took attendance um and I
remember like showing up late in this
teacher just be like you know what in
front of everyone she's like you show up
late one more time and I'm going to give
you an F because there's a teacher you
have to be on time and you have not come
on time to any of these classes so you
come back again late you better be
focused and be on time cuz I'll give you
an F I swear but you made it fast
forward to the next week I wake up I'm
running late ooh
genius idea I snatch a red apple
I walk into class probably 20 minutes
late she's looking at me and I
go over just like real quiet and pull
this shiny red apple out of my jacket
and put it on her desk and like go and
sit down quietly and she just picks it
up and she looks at it she looks at me
and she's like you you really know how
to charm an old elementary school
teacher and she's like Touche Harley
Touche and like just let me say and I
didn't I didn't come late to any other
classes after that but I did get the by
just for being like kind of like you
know a little a little you know you know
playing the hates me yeah you know you
don't wanna read I have this guy in half
big dummy he said it was a plan B so if
it was a plan B like what was it more
specifically what was plan a plan a was
I'm going to I'm gonna I'm gonna make
movies I'm gonna be in movies and I'm
gonna make them are you doing any yeah
so in university this was the best part
of elementary education was you would do
presentations things like that how can
you teach the kids to to do something
that's fun and to make it fun so one
thing that maybe wouldn't charm the
teachers now but sure as hell worked in
2005 was you make a video as your
project oh yeah so if I had a video that
would accompany what I'm doing that like
the teachers always love that I got I
got a 100 percent every time we did
group projects I was talking with my
cans deal we're into a video I'm gonna
do the filming I'm gonna do the editing
we're gonna be cool I'm gonna write it
you just gotta come meet me at school on
this day we're in a film it you just
play this person this person this person
we're gonna include everything we need
in the video and we're gonna let the
video play for our presentation and I
always cleared it with the teacher first
and I always made these these goofy
silly videos and the teachers always
loved them so I was making videos in
class too
so by the time I got to my last semester
it was like people were kind of excited
about what would be my school project
video that I would that I would be and
it was like you know like 75% of time
it's like a rap video you know like we
have to teach like like I did one like
sodium and you there's like this like
hardcore gangster rap video you know
teaching kids about sodium and and and
was it
censored with
um no there was just no swearing it was
very very capitated PG sure okay
so I was doing that at the time and what
I was also doing was when I was
substituting I would bring a notebook
with me because I'm still to this day
there's nothing nothing more amusing
than being in a class at least for me of
like 14 year olds 30 14 year olds and
I'm watching how they interact and speak
to each other and everything it's just
so it's so funny it's just we don't act
like that anymore it's just everyone
completely uncensored with the mix of
people that would just shut out the
whole world depending on who the student
is and who the students are they're just
you're just looking at like intense
personalities it's you know you see
people on the bus and everyone's just
sitting there mm-hmm
you know you barely get personality but
in high school in class is like yeah the
next 10 minutes you guys could do what
you want you know just keep it like at a
level these kids would interact with and
you're getting like 30 personalities
like clear-cut like you see it like
quiet kids go over and like start
pulling out like magic cards and like
talking and like you know so other guys
like trying to be cool in front of the
girls and being loud and you know like
and just like sitting on the desk like
the things that they say and everything
like that and what the focus is I just
would bring in a notebook and I would
like write so I would write you know
script ideas like you know show ideas
things that I thought were you know good
ideas and then I would go home and on
the weekends I would film these and and
I made a rap video once and and my
brother shared it with one of his
students who ended up telling all the
other students so when I got to the
school once like he was also a teacher
yeah yeah same school that's how I got
into substituting our substitutes for
his classes so when I got there like got
to the point where these students had
seen like my earliest videos before
epicMealTime or anything but just like
you know a whole bunch of them like what
type of rap videos are we talking about
sodium you know it's called pop and
Perrier and it's just like me and like
two buddies and it's you know where the
whole chorus was three straight guys in
a Crown Victoria pop and Perrier and we
were like three dudes like sitting in
the front
bench of a Crown Vic Crown Victoria car
pouring like bubbly water all over
ourselves in slow-mo and rapping with
like girls shaking their asses and it
was like a weird video like I don't know
we just did it to be like ever look
let's share this on Facebook for our
friends sounds great so you're making
rap videos and then but when you talk
him about wanting to make movies what
did you have a vision for was it like
I'm gonna do YouTube stuff because that
was already a thing no it wasn't like
YouTube it was like 2006 like no one's
getting paid on YouTube it's like you
know Time magazine has the reflective
cover that says you are the star you are
the man of the year or whatever remember
that year yes and it's like you know
they're writing about Smosh a million
views combined crossed and it's like I'm
all big deal but like to me it was just
like I can film something and I could
put it on the Internet finally there's a
place where I could put it because now I
could share it on Facebook so no one is
you know no one has to come over and we
have to find a VHS or VCR that'll play
this you know yeah and we get to share
it so I ended up you know I would I
would film some stuff and a buddy of
mine wrote this script where I would be
a I'm like I'm big and hairy and I'm
just like a big kid and I I'm gonna open
up a lemonade stand I open up a lemonade
stand and my mom ends up like taking my
money from it and it's like a funny like
four minutes short movie kind of but it
was filmed with an awesome camera and I
kind of saw it was the first time I had
been in something that looked like
professional lose my buddy was in this
film program and so he had this awesome
camera and like lights and there was a
director and I got to begin and like
watch myself after and I was like this
is awesome I was like this is like you
know I finally got to do something like
this so when I started writing stuff I
wrote one that was like it's this like
the guy's a gangster and it's he's
remembering his accounts of like how he
rose to becoming a gangster
you know only talking about like a 20
year old dude and he's like it's all
like takes place in his apartment I'm
writing this kids show so I'm like I'm
an education I could leverage being a
teacher into making
kids show whenever I used to do that I
used to always talk with my buddy I'd
always be like lunchbox money like
that's what we call the working title
for that kid show what's called lunchbox
money because I was like your dude you
know the Wiggles are billionaires yeah
sigh gap dude
kids show let's do this so it's all
about a kids show so I thought it was
like that's what was gonna be the money
make I'm gonna be a pee-wee Herman and
it's gonna be great and it's and we're
always like yellow lunchbox money that's
what used to say we're gonna sell
lunchboxes and it's funny cuz lunchbox
money ends up being YouTube money right
on Epic Meal Time but at the same time
I'm writing things and filming things
and I entered this contest called John
Tesh rock rap dribble dance contest and
it was John Tesh the NBC NB NBC and it
was taken the Peppa Peppa Peppa parapa
parapa parapa uh-huh one minute that
John Tesh sample you have to rap dribble
or dance in the video I thought John
Tesh was the guy from Entertainment
Tonight the same guy you know live at
Red Rocks John - yes exactly
oh really yeah I saw him in a sushi
place about a month ago
oh really yeah Sherman Oaks well he
started Epic Meal Time he did this this
contest and I I came in first place in
the contest me and a buddy of mine
so the first-place prize with five was
$5,000 American fact then you say
American is if I thought I was American
cuz it meant to us 7,500 Canadian oh now
it's like $5,000 got it it's just
dollars all around so I got five
thousand dollars American
so seven thousand five hundred dollars
by winning first place in this contest
this goofy contest where I'm like
rapping and dribbling and dancing with
my buddy and it's all just goofy and
early in a basketball yeah but like
poorly okay the video is on the internet
you can look it up well you won I can't
argue with that so so we we took the
money we bought this camera and we were
like we're gonna go we're gonna film
rap videos and we're gonna and now I got
into production now I was like I'm going
to edit I'm gonna learn how to film and
lights and all that I'm gonna learn
the backend of it you know and at the
same time I started taking Meisner
acting classes and I would go to
auditions and I go to auditions and
they're like you know read these lines
and read them they're like you know what
you could play thug number three your
big dude stand in the corner cross your
arms and like that kind of a seen
nothing yet happened numerous times plus
I live in Montreal so the acting is in
French there's lots of French
productions not English ones because the
way it works in Montreal is if you're
filming in Montreal your crew has to be
French 75% of the crew or something like
that so if you don't speak French you
have to get a translator so now a lot of
people don't work there under those
conditions so a lot of the filming is in
French so I can't act in French and you
know I was getting like just never
really getting roles so I was like I'm
gonna buy a camera learn how to film and
edit I'm gonna make my own show starring
me and I'm gonna get all the lines okay
so that's what I'm gonna do
yeah all English and so I'm still a
teacher at this point yeah I'm doing at
the same time so I I got this contest me
and my partner we won and we we started
filming like weddings trying to and wrap
videos and like a show like a gaming
show which is actually still the
Internet's called the game haters and
it's like actually still there this old
with one guy that's on Epic Meal Time
now a mayor and another old buddy of
mine and I'm totally behind the camera
like filming it I'm just not in front of
it oh really
Danny oh game yeah it's like reviewing
video games okay and like yeah it's just
like a video game review show it's just
and it's just me learning and it's the
first thing I've ever filmed and edited
so uh one day were filming wedding and
just briefly the cameras under a blanket
but in the middle of day like 3:00 p.m.
on the busy street someone smashed the
window and took the camera somebody
stole your camera camera so I had it had
it insured though at everything insured
and what happened was it was the time
that about the 7d the Canon 7d came out
with an update to let it film mm-hm
so when I went back to get a camera the
guy pitched me on the 7d
and when I got it it just looked so much
better than any other camera I'd ever
had at the time it looked like really
official right so that's when I was like
some things are in focus and some things
out of yeah it was nuts
it was great that's really what came
down yeah yeah yeah that's just there
needs to be a lot of lights yeah and
needs gonna be $2,000 for every lens
uh-huh so yeah I bought it and I just
started filming like crazy and I started
filming everything and then I saw one
day I saw a pizza I used to go to the
site called this is why you're fat calm
and I thought I saw a pizza and someone
put french fries on it and a hamburger
and a big stack of money and a gun and
it was just like such a funny picture
cuz it was like just to take french
fries and put it on a pizza was just so
stupid but like to put like a burger
also like a happy meal mm-hmm but the
idea that there was a gun there in a
stack of money was so like just that
whole mix mm-hmm like I looked at it and
I was like can happy meal on a pizza
player gangster
exactly so I I you know I called up my
buddies and I'm like here's the deal
look at this picture we're gonna do is
we're gonna go to all the fast food
place and we're gonna put it on this
pizza mm-hm and that's what we did and I
just had my camera and I was like you
know I had my buddy film it and you know
we go we got all the stuff and put it on
and I'm just kind of like riffing like
yeah Mac baby and I'm just saying doing
it it's just genuine excitement it's
just like a real life like experience we
throw it on and anyways I put it on my
computer and I start focusing on
lunchbox money cuz like I'm gonna make a
kids show mmm and it's gonna it's gonna
be baller dog be rolling in lunchbox
money and wiggles where's that we were
it was all like it was like experiencing
learning through like rap and hip-hop it
was supposed to be like a real you know
funky fresh learning experience you know
a lot of yeah I I thought or it could be
you know
it's never too late but she was sitting
on this other footage just think yes
that was fun yeah that was filming music
videos going over like filming local
rappers like telling them I'll film
their video for a hundred bucks they're
telling me 20 bucks now 80 bucks after
the video getting stiffed 480 bucks like
doing all that and meanwhile I have this
like folder on my computer that's just
titled worst pizza ever and like I go
back and at the time I'm like I'm
editing it like it's a trailer like it's
all like I'm editing it just for fun and
it's like you know like 2010 two men go
on a quest for the most epic pizza of
all time and like I'm kind of piecing it
together and it's just like it's this
seven-minute weird trailer there's like
a lot of burping footage in it that we
all thought was really hilarious these
ugly faces that I'm making them as I'm
really burping and I just kind of start
cutting it up and cutting it up and like
I'm usually out it no no no vo okay I
feel at all on that one and I'm just
kind of like cutting it and cutting and
cutting and then I just like was like
you know what like between lunch box
money and everything like I just want to
release this video cuz I think people
will like it it's cool and when I cut it
down to about like the two-minute mark
and I watch it I like watch it again
like I wanted to see it again and I
watched it a couple times and I was like
this is really like good I'm like now
that it's a two minutes this is like one
of the best things I've ever done
so I I shortened it more and I threw on
a calorie counter by like researching
everything that was there and I was like
when I go on this is why you're fat or
when I go looking at food on the
internet like just for fun because one
of the things I look at like the
calories is always interesting to me so
how many is this and I do the couch I'm
like oh 5,000 calories yeah this is
crazy so I add it and I look at it I'm
like this is this is a great video in my
opinion and I think this video will get
10,000 views so I need to think of a
name for it so I started like throwing
it out and all my buddy who's like I'm
inviting people over I'm going over my
buddy's house a lot of my buddies would
mean a friend's backyard a bunch of the
guys that are on Epic Meal Time now even
and like we're watching this video and
like what are we gonna call it what will
it be called you know now you called the
folder worst pizza ever
the video title was ended up being put
up as the worst pizza ever okay cuz we
wanted to say it something that would be
like oh I want to see what the worst
pizza ever is right yeah so we ended up
before it even goes up we settle on the
name Epic Meal Time so for the channel
for the channels you want to show yeah
and the whole thing was if this video
does well and gets like 10,000 views
we'll do another one next week okay cuz
I go on this is why you're fat calm a
lot and there's some there that should
be in video form only in pictures so I
put the video up and I I go to to
BuzzFeed and read it and Buzz Sweden
read it essentially made the first
epicMealTime popular you got 125
thousand views I got an email from
BuzzFeed being like your video is uh is
being pushed to the front page because
one of the editors likes it and like I
look on Reddit and it's like my buddy
tells me it's like on the front page so
I'm like crazy and it has 125 thousand
views I'm like this is this is so nuts
you know so I'm all but you're also
you're like this it's not because like
this is working yeah you were thinking
in terms of a show I'm gonna do this
again yeah and so when it actually
happens it's different than if it
happens oh wait actually is happening
yeah so now there's like a pressure
almost so I go back to like this is why
you're fat I see another idea that I
want to expand on it was a poutine
sandwich between two slices of french
toast and it was called the the French
Quebecer and I I thought there I was
like throwing up to the buddies and
everything like do we come out as
Canadian or do we play it like were you
know like Americans and yeah we'd like
crazy and just not kind of talk about it
mm-hmm and I ended up just deciding like
you know what will come out as Canadians
because the second meal is gonna be a
french-canadian idea and we I think
we'll kind of bypass the whole obstacle
of yeah
Americans would do this you know cuz
there's always to this stage to like
they're Canadians you idiot that still
is there so we kind of bypassed that
whole obstacle by just being Canadian
and we came out the next idea was
the angry french-canadian which was a
baguette french toasted with poutine and
hotdogs and syrup and bacon and we made
the video and it got 600,000 views
that's a good episode - yeah and is
great and I went to I was substituting
that week like three days after that six
hundred thousand feet video came out and
I got to school and every single kid had
seen the video like everyone that's the
second video and everyone's seen it so
the thing about Epic Meal Time is people
always are like oh yeah it's you're
lucky cuz it was popular right away mmm
it's like you know how many school
projects and like video game review
shows and music videos right I put on
YouTube how many other channels did you
had you create it on YouTube up into
that point trying different stuff five
channels before that trying things but
like that no one saw right cuz they just
never got popular they never got more
than like 4000 views and so yeah so when
this one did that 600,000 views and the
kids were like that in school I
immediate was like nope done done I'm
like this now this now I'm like I'm
going to I have like some teaching money
I have like 4 grand in my bank that I
save just from teaching and I'm going to
put it in this like we it's just got to
happen every week I realized like at the
after five days after video goes up
you're forgotten like it's the view stop
when the video was just done and so
that's when I was like it has to happen
every Tuesday like we can't miss one
it's got to keep going because right off
the bat you quit your job in the second
video and then week three you're like
every Tuesday I'm doing this yeah and
this is 2010 yeah my brother does a lot
of the background stuff but everything
creatively would funnel through me which
has now changed because you know we have
I trust a lot of the guys now back then
I didn't really trust anyone I was
taking on too much for myself and there
was employment there was a point where I
thought I wasn't drop dead like I was
gonna die just because I was editing the
videos myself setting up the production
for the next one is taking every calls
so I was working like 10-hour day
because like I didn't want to give the
editing to someone else
for example for how long of a period of
time the first like 85 episodes Wow so
over a year and how crazy did a gift for
you personally and mentally at that
point if you said you're about to drop
dead it was just because like it was at
a time like like doing this buyout like
traveling like to go film in different
places and like breaking up with a
girlfriend at the time and just
everything was shows like no rest ever
oh so you're still going to do camp no
there was that you can do camp was done
after so I mean so it specifically if
you had a girlfriend you camp yeah right
so how did that go down I mean in terms
of how did what you were doing that
mealtime get so involved that you
couldn't carry on a relationship because
it was like I would be going and editing
late night and the guys would be there
but her presence wasn't nesting get
along with some of the guys it wasn't
necessarily conducive to the creation
and the creativity was she in some of
the early videos yeah she was actually
because written I watch the videos and
we're like okay there's a whole bunch of
guys and a whole lot of food and there's
one girl
we're wondering why isn't there more of
a girl yeah well yeah we do remember
watching some of the early episodes and
then when the girls would start eating
was like what it's a lot more enjoyable
to watch a female for me personally
watch a female even a male eat so I was
like well why don't they do more of this
well so like early on I was like the
fifth episode and I was like this is
getting kind of good let's get some
girls in here that's when even in that
episode like I'm like I'm like a
Macallan you want girls we got girls cuz
like we had one girl before people are
like more girls so we made a point being
like more girls and they went through
this whole point was like girls and like
we did like videos with like 16 girls
eating mac and cheese and like 40 girls
eating sausages and the sausage fest and
it was like such a thing and then we got
kind of like we still love girls on it
but we stopped doing like girls for the
sake of just being like yeah you know
like I mean there's plenty of place you
can go
Koff on the internet you don't need to
watch up in real-time cough so we just
kind of like just when it when it when
it when it comes to you know when
something is like you know like we're
not like we never we always thought
about it we never went down the path of
just having like you know girls in
bikinis just cooking every week just to
be doing it you know I didn't want to
detach the personality of you and in a
crew away from yeah we thought it was
very funny that there wasn't girls in
the kitchen like it's it's like dudes
like cooking like a girl's cooking it
kind of ruined it for us you know in a
way kind of like yeah we got to do we
like the idea of us cooking for girls
ultimately but you know girls but it
status a theme throughout like we still
have females on on episodes but we just
never you know we have specials like we
did meat cake and I was like we have
like nine girls in that episode that
came out in February
right so 85 episodes and you're doing
this thing essentially single-handedly
and it's it's all you can commit your
time to it's taking its toll putting all
your energy into this thing first on
that relationship now was that just
because you put her in the video and
then all you broke up it was because you
were none of the video it's like so like
like I would edit I would be editing
until 3 a.m. and like where are you like
I'm working you're not working you're
hanging out with your friends well
that's the tricky thing is I kind of
have this awesome show where my work is
hanging out with my friends you know and
that's like so we would you know we'd
like kickin me and my buddies and we're
editing like I'm editing but I would
haven't hooked up to a big screen and
everyone's like you know laughing and
we're all part of it like you know
watching it people early epicMealTime
like people would come over and like
watch the editing it was you know I'd
have like 5 people there and we're
editing in like Reno do this do that
people suggesting is fun like having
some drinks was cool so she wasn't good
in those scenarios cuz how much longer
and like that sucks when you're trying
to be funny and stuff like that but yeah
that just eventually got to the point
where it couldn't just couldn't happen
anymore it was just wasn't good
we were out once and
and like I got rushed by some fans one
wearing a t-shirt on Epic Meal Time
t-shirt but they were female and she
didn't like that and so it turned into
an ugly situation but I kind of like was
torn between the fact that you know no
matter what this person they support
what I'm doing like because that person
bought a shirt like I don't maybe we
don't have to go teach one more day you
know and I could continue doing this
something that's fun so when when that
started to be compromised like basically
after that point
anyone who kind of got to the point
where they were compromising the show or
anything like that like that that would
just be the end of it and so she got the
one which she started to compromise it
and then so it just ended you know and a
mat carried on like same thing with like
the chef who kind of overstepped his
boundaries like he would my tear and you
know before epicMealTime happened like I
sat down and read it was just by chance
but it's it's so funny because like I
said I read the secret mm-hm and I read
these Malcolm Gladwell books like
tipping point and and if you're a read
who moved my cheese familiar with it I
haven't read it whom I choose a good one
it's basically saying like you know
these these mics are stuck in a lab and
there's a big pile of cheese it's like
60 60 pages this book there's a big pile
of cheese and like they're there and
they're eating the cheese and you know
they they split up because one is like
you know this cheese isn't gonna be here
forever I want to find more cheese and
say but we have so much cheese here and
it's like yeah but that cheese isn't
forever
so let's go find something else and they
all split up and you know the mouse ends
up finding you know a lot more cheese
like infinite cheese essentially from
what I remember and the whole point like
being like if that cheese was like my
teaching job leaving it on the second
week to go find more cheese which would
be you know production and stuff that I
love then that would be the equivalent
of it and then you know you read the
seeker it's all like positive thing is
basically a mumbo-jumbo like you know
just visualize and laws of attraction
but like I just got caught up reading it
because it's just you know this is I
like to be positive and I want to be
positive and reading this makes me feel
like that's positive and then reading
something like
tipping point where it's like you know
how this and that makes something
popular and then I read outliers
outliers was interesting because when I
when I read outliers it saying how
certain people are good at certain
things like how in hockey people born in
January February March make up most of
the NHL now why is that so that's
because when you're born in January
February March people born in January
and people born in December let's say
are both five years old so they're on
the five year old team but someone who's
born in January is still a year older
than someone born in December and at
five years old that's a big difference
mentally and physically that kid is a
much better human than the other one so
he's good at hockey so now that kid
because he's good at hockey at five
years old he makes the Triple A team
December kid makes the double a team
just have happened triple a because it's
triple a they practice five times a week
the double a kid only practices three
times a week because it's doubly it's
not as big a deal so then that he was
going and years later this
self-fulfilling prophecy of the kid
being born in January oh he's better
well no he's just twelve eleven months
older he's not better let the other kid
grow for eleven months that continues as
he practices more in plays more so now
he actually is better and that goes into
this whole thing of him talking about
10,000 hours to be great at something
and so I sat and i looked at youtube and
i was looking at the top youtubers and
everything and i'm looking at them and i
was just like you know they're the top
20 at the time they were all male and
they were all born from like you know
1980 to 1988 and i was just like i fall
in that and it's this time where it's
like i'm not too old that i can't grasp
something like uploading a video and
editing on software and installing
software and working on a computer and
uploading but i'm also not too young
that i grew up an elementary school
playing call of duty online and being on
facebook i was a human and i went
outside and played so i'm like in my
head I'm like I think I'm an outlier in
this respect that I can I I'm tech savvy
enough to go in front of a camera but
I'm not you know socially awkward having
only played battle Call of Duty online
or anything like I'm a human being I
could probably go and be relatable and
and that's when I kind of went to
youtube and that went to epic Meal Time
and I just kind of followed this flow of
of the books at the time but you know it
gave me like a drive and you know Epic
Meal Time and everything we do is
something that I got really protective
over that whole cheese analogy is
something that will always apply in life
so how about if you ever just orient if
you ever stop and look at your cheese
and be like hmm like then that's when
you know that you know you just chase
the next one and before you know before
epicMealTime views now or at like thirty
percent of what they used to be
before that even happened I just looked
took one look at YouTube and was like my
whole business relies on the on another
company like another business controls
my business if at any moment they're
like oh no more videos it's it's over or
like you know it's happened before a
change on YouTube can affect some people
in certain ways and other people in
other ways but not just them their
entire business so right from the
beginning YouTube was just a cheese that
needed to be moved from an epic meal
time itself is also a cheese that
doesn't necessarily need to be moved
from but there is other cheese out there
so Epic Meal Time is something that you
know when it first started when I think
meal time first first started and it
started to roll and you know it was
getting like at the time two million
views in a week I looked at it and I was
like this will go on for five years it
will be five years of this show and
there was just a number I had now we're
like at year three and I'm like like
maybe I was wrong maybe YouTube isn't
even around for that five year so I was
talking about you know can Epic Meal
Time be around for two years can-can
YouTube be around for two years are we
all gonna be watching videos on our
phones and stuff still is it still like
the right thing is it still the right
business like you know what is it
at the end of the day
happy that you know I kind of went out
there performed got to do that I have
the experience I have a full-on
production company I can go and I can go
and make a movie like I always wanted to
do right now yeah I mean it's I think
we'd all agree it's a privilege to do
what we're able to do for a living and
you know I'll say it's also privileged
to talk to you and to get to know your
mindset and so we we look forward to
more from you sir and thanks for the
thanks I drafted by the way yeah you got
to sign the table I know I'm looking at
it I'm like I I've been trying to figure
out where I'm gonna sign it grab that
sharpie up there make it make it
official hell yeah I do ice get the sign
at wall talking you guys yeah yeah kind
of 3d block letters you can do anything
you want but that's encouraged actually
that was out here biscuit with Harley
Morenstein I think that we have a more
complete if not complete picture of the
sauce boss you know he was a teacher for
a while but I think the thing that I'm
kind of coming away from the
conversation with is that he was a
student you know a student of the
students that he was teaching you know
and the students of YouTube he was a
student of YouTube and how to make that
a success extremely committed to that
reading books being influenced as a
calculated business man very impressive
right for so for those of you out there
who are like you know I want to be a
youtuber for a living that's what I want
to do I think maybe that was a little
profile in this isn't just okay I got
one idea and just somebody's got to give
me the chance to do it we're talking
about a guy that saw success in his
sixth youtube channel but then he was
totally ready I was I mean released two
videos within the span of two weeks then
quit his job and was totally ready to do
it every single week after that there
was no second guessing it was just like
he was like oh this is it I'm cleaning
out the bank account and I'm going for
it and well it worked and you know and
in a guy like that who
has so many different ambitions and he's
trying so many different things and he's
always busy trying to work on another
idea you know I'm excited with somebody
has a mentality like that it changes
changing so much I would just like to be
able to fast forward like 10 years and
be like alright what happened in the
next decade
because we feel that way about ourselves
and what we what we hope to accomplish
and where things are going there's so
many question marks right and so much of
our thoughts are similar to his I mean
it was encouraging encouraging talking
to him especially with such a positive
outlook and a confident outlook on
things so thanks to Harley and thank you
for listening to this ear biscuit again
Hank we do this every week and we can
handle more people if you want to invite
them to listen to your biscuits along
with you or through their own stream we
encourage can do that we encourage you
to share the biscuits they have the
ability to be divided infinitely and
taste as good to everyone else thank you
listen to us next week
[Music]
[Music]